[Music]
today we'll be using simple geometry to
expand the trigonometric identities sine
alpha + beta + cosine alpha + beta
let's begin look at this diagram this
line is of length 1 unit it makes an
angle of beta with the x-axis let's drop
a perpendicular from this point to the
x-axis we get a right triangle this is
the opposite side and this is the
adjacent side the opposite side is of
length sine beta and the adjacent side
is of length cos beta now let's rotate
this triangle counterclockwise by alpha
this is the new position of the triangle
this angle is alpha now remember we
rotated the triangle by alpha we drop a
perpendicular from this vertex of a
right triangle to the x-axis and we get
this right triangle look at this
triangle carefully its hypotenuse is cos
beta we want to know the measure of this
opposite side and this adjacent side for
this triangle now we know that sine
alpha is the opposite side over the
hypotenuse we see that the hypotenuse
for this triangle is cos beta so we
replace the denominator with cos beta we
get the opposite side as sine alpha cos
beta similarly we know that cos alpha is
the adjacent side over the hypotenuse
can you tell me what the adjacent side
is yes it's cos alpha cos beta remember
we want to find sine alpha + beta +
cosine alpha plus beta now notice this
angle here the measure of this angle is
alpha plus beta if we drop a
perpendicular from this point we get a
right triangle with this angle as alpha
plus beta can you tell me what is the
opposite side for this triangle yes its
sine alpha + beta
and what is the adjacent side that's
right it is cos alpha plus beta all we
need to do is find the length of the
opposite and the adjacent sides in much
simpler terms how do we use this diagram
to find sine alpha plus beta and cos
alpha plus beta we are going to draw two
lines now one here and one here this
angle formed here is a right angle
notice we get this rectangle as a result
why do we need this rectangle that's
because it will help us find sine alpha
plus beta and cos alpha plus beta how
does it help us find the value of sine
alpha plus beta let's understand we know
that the opposite sides of the rectangle
are equal so this side is equal to this
side and this side is equal to this side
let's focus on these two sides we know
that they're equal that means sine alpha
plus beta is this length Plus this
length we know that this length is sine
alpha cos beta we just found that out
now all we need is this length so we can
say that sine alpha plus beta is sine
alpha cos beta plus some value let's
find this length look at this triangle
now it's a right triangle the hypotenuse
is sine beta and if we know this angle
we can easily find the length of this
side what's the measure of this angle
yes this angle is alpha that's because
this angle is 90 and this one is 90
minus alpha and together these three
angles add up to give us 180 degrees
take a few seconds to understand how we
got this angle as alpha with the help of
alpha we get this side as sine beta cos
alpha and this sine as sine beta sine
alpha now that we have this length we
can say that sine alpha plus beta is
sine alpha cos beta plus
cos alpha sine beta we found sine alpha
plus beta now we need to find cos alpha
plus beta now cos alpha plus beta is
this length minus this length we know
this length
it's sine alpha sine beta that's because
these two sides are equal they are
opposite sides of this rectangle so cos
alpha plus beta is cos alpha cos beta
minus sine alpha sine beta so we see how
simple geometry helped us express these
identities in simpler terms in our next
video we will learn about other
trigonometric identities
[Music]